- The number one variable
of growing your business in this room
that is practical, achievable, doable,
is how serious you take making
content on the internet.
It's that simple.
No matter what anybody in this
room says to me of why no,
because they've never started
and they have an ideology
or because they've made
45 posts on Instagram
and haven't sold anything yet.
No matter what your excuse is,
I promise you social media
is not broken in that story.
You're the one that's broken.
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
One of the great things about COVID
is it breaks your patterns, right?
Something that monumental
obviously there's so many
things that are challenging
and difficult and obviously devastating,
but when you're able to make
it to the other side of a war
or a pandemic or a challenging
time in one's life,
what was specific about this pandemic
was it gave you time to kind of slow down,
even if you were panicking up front,
which is what I was doing.
Literally within the first
couple days of the shutdown,
four of our top five clients emailed us
and said we're not gonna
be paying you for a while.
And the way I build my company
is for top line growth.
I'm incredibly not
incentivized for profit,
which means we're running
on very tight margin.
So not getting paid is always a challenge.
And then on top of everything else,
Vayner's size was very, very unique
in that we were not small
enough and not big enough,
so we got $0.0 from anybody.
And so we had to navigate.
And after all that was done
and what is the framework of so much
of what I'm thinking about
now started to emerge.
And the reality is that I can sit here
knowing this industry extremely well,
knowing the enormity of
the advantage of this room,
because there's so many
immigrants in the room
and that intro is absolutely true.
Life is about understanding
the alternative.
It's really hard to
complain about what milk
was put in your Starbucks
when you came from the fucking dirt.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
So there's a lot that we
don't need to touch on
in this room.
I could talk about what I
think you should be doing
from a content standpoint,
because the reality is I promise you
the number one variable
of growing your business in this room
that is practical, achievable, doable,
is how serious you take making
content on the internet.
It's that simple.
No matter what anybody in this
room says to me of why no,
because they've never started
and they have an ideology
or because they've made 45 posts
on Instagram and haven't
sold anything yet.
No matter what your excuse is,
I promise you social media
is not broken in that story.
You're the one that's broken.
It was funny, last week someone's like,
"Gary, you've been
talking about LinkedIn,"
and he showed me the posts and
he's like, it's not working.
And in the post,
I'm talking about making
content in the feed of LinkedIn,
knowing who you're trying to reach,
running ads against the
employees of those organizations
for content in the feed.
And then I ask him what he's doing.
And he's spamming people by
paying a hundred bucks a month
for a script that just
emails people on LinkedIn.
That little story is something
I think about every day.
The ROI I like to say of a basketball
is billions of dollars for LeBron James.
It's zero for me.
How one plays with the tools
is the variable of success.
And so we can get into the
mindset, very much the intro,
which was lovely, thank you, and in depth,
I do believe that the far majority
of what is the opportunity in
this room or the limitation
sits in two very simple categories.
One's uncomfortably black and white
and one is remarkably gray.
The black and white is
what I just started with.
Until you start making
dozens of videos, pictures,
and written articles a week,
you will continue to leave
an extraordinary amount
of money on the table
and somebody sitting next to you
is gonna do it and take your market share.
And I don't care if you've been the queen
of that city for 30 years
and work on your reputation,
slowly but surely you will lose,
because that's what always
happens in business.
If that wasn't the case,
IBM would still be winning.
I love this industry and I
love OGs 'cause my dad's an OG.
Shit, I started so young I'm an OG.
Like, I love OG life
and it is absolutely
building on reputation.
But I love when an agent says to me,
"Dear, you don't get it.
I dominate this town
for the last 30 years."
I'm like, "Dear, you don't get it."
You don't get it.
Much bigger companies than you
have gone outta business
with fucking audacity.
And it is audacity in 2022.
And this is very clear.
If you're sitting in the crowd
and you're not doing this work,
it's only two things and
they're both interesting.
One is audacity.
You're audacious that what you
did in 1993 or 2001 or 2007
is enough for you to dominate 2022.
Or you've lost your
ambition, which is okay.
I don't think of that as a bad thing.
I don't think it's a bad thing
that you're not as hungry.
Maybe you've scratched your itch.
Maybe you do wanna do
other parts in your life.
But look, don't lie to yourself
and understand yourself on
where you are in your journey.
2022 is gonna be a remarkable
opportunity for this room.
The question is very simple though.
Who's gonna actually put in
the 30 hours of work, starting today,
to actually know how to do pictures
and videos and written words
on these platforms and who's not.
And it becomes a very simple game.
It's a black and white prescriptive game.
Either you're good at it or you're not,
no different than basketball.
We need to have a very big conversation
in the business world
about how much kindness,
compassion, empathy, are
the superpowers of business.
People don't think so.
When I talk about kindness
and I talk about it a lot,
my favorite email is like title, all caps,
"Gary, you are wrong."
I'm like, here we go.
I open it up.
"You don't get it, Gary,
you talk about kindness.
I'm always kind and everybody
takes advantage of me
and walks all over me."
And I reply, "Hey, Rick.
Maybe you're manipulating the situation
because you want somebody to
walk all over you a little bit
'cause you're actually subconsciously
trying to create leverage."
Because let me promise you one
thing about actual kindness
if you're confused by the definition.
Actual kindness means
giving without expectation.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
And I believe in business
what is very clear to me
is people think kindness
and they use kindness,
but what it really is, is a
slight version of manipulation.
You're doing something
with thinking something
else is gonna happen.
You're referring 'cause
you think you're gonna...
And it's all good.
It's nice to maybe think,
but don't confuse that with kindness.
That's called strategy.
Don't say you're kind, say
you're throwing out reels
and trying to hope it returns.
Own what it actually is.
I was at a conference
like this many years ago
and I had just invested in Uber
and it was the taxi and
limo national convention.
So I'm given my talk and I
finally throw it out there.
And as you can imagine,
the room wasn't thrilled with
me, but it was a discussion.
And all I saw, all I saw
was question after question,
statement after statement that
was why it wasn't gonna work.
And all of the answers were regulation.
"Gary, this is not gonna work
because we're gonna pay
the politicians off."
Similar to how I hear car dealerships
and car people talk about
Tesla or direct to consumer.
I promise you when
technology is coming along,
hoping for regulation
is always going to be a bad strategy.
My favorite is everybody
who hates big government
'cause they're an entrepreneur.
But then when something
comes along and fucks you up,
you love the government, don't ya?
So when the blockchain comes
and starts taking out fees,
you better shut your
fucking mouth in this room
and notice how few claps just happened.
Why do I bring that up right now?
Not to razz, not to scare,
because I want you to do
the 50 hours of homework
so you can innovate.
What blows my mind is people's inability
to put in the work in
the face of information.
All of you know that this
blockchain thing is brewing.
You've definitely heard
about Bitcoin at this point.
You've probably maybe heard of Ethereum.
It's happening and it's gonna
affect this industry soonest.
This is the book industry
for the internet.
The blockchain is contracts.
Please understand that, please.
It's a very important thing.
Please spend 15 hours Googling
Ethereum and smart contracts.
Get educated, not to play defense,
but to play offense.
You do 15 to 30 hours of homework,
you might just change your career.
You might shift slightly
in what you're doing
now to something else.
It's a remarkable time.
And one thing I know about
an immigrant-centric reality
is it's not scared to put in the work.
And I really know this statement.
It likes to pick which
work it wants to do.
People don't like change,
and change is the only guarantee.
What the blockchain eventually
will do is change the face
of what brokerages
leverages in the ecosystem.
Right now is the time
to build your personal
brand on the internet.
And I mean right now.
How you do that can be totally different.
You don't need to be over
the top or curse like me.
You need to be you.
I'm me. You be you.
But what you need to do
is start producing content
to educate people on who you are.
If you're uncomfortable
with the way you look
and you don't wanna be on video,
then do audio and do a podcast.
If you are not sure that
you can handle the camera,
then write on LinkedIn or Facebook.
If you feel more comfortable
being the hostess with the mostest,
start a Facebook group
regionally within your area.
One of the greatest arbitrages
in this industry right now
is starting a Facebook
group for the local area
where you sell around the
town, not around selling homes,
bringing people in, building community,
and then just happening to be the person
that's hosting that group
and picking up the business.
These are the black and white
tactics available to you.
How you build your team
and how much empathy you
have for the consumer
on the other side is the other variable.
But the opportunity is staggering.
It is staggering.
The speed in which people are
changing what they consume,
which then dictates what they think,
which then dictates how they buy,
is at a level we've never seen before.
I come here, fly across the country
and fly back for one reason:
to put so much pressure on this room
to do the homework, to do the homework.
I mean it.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
The opportunity is so real.
You are literally one, one,
because I'm on the receiving
end of these messages.
You're one viral TikTok video away
from selling 13 homes because of it.
And you don't go in there and
start doing the latest dance.
You're trying to sell homes.
And you're more than welcome
to shake your ass, fine,
but it's a lot more interesting
to talk about what you wanna talk about,
but making it contextual to the room.
People say no so much.
TikTok's fastest-growing
demo is 38 to 55-year-olds.
You can still think it's 12-year-olds.
It hasn't been 12-year-olds for two years.
That's the game of no
versus the game of yes.
That's the game of staying curious.
The biggest, biggest
vulnerability to people
in business today trying
to sell to human beings
is their unbelievable
calmness and interest
in saying the word no
and their visceral reaction
to the idea of maybe.
The innovation that we're
living through is big.
The opportunity is even bigger,
but this requires homework.
Before you decide that content
on social media can't sell for you,
did you really do the 20 hours of homework
and the 50 hours of you doing it?
It doesn't count when you have your niece
do six posts for you.
This world is reading about
pushups instead of doing them.
That's actually not even true.
I wish this was a game
of people reading about
pushups and not doing it.
We're not even reading about pushups.
We're dismissing pushups
before we even read about them.
I ask you and implore you
here today, my friends,
to open up your heart to curiosity,
to open up your eyes
to the reality of what's
happening in our society
and how people are making their decisions
and to shed your preconceived notions
and start putting in the work.
For a lot of us, me included,
it was easy to put in
the hard labor, right?
It was easy to put in the work.
It's much more challenging
to figure out the new technologies.
The problem is, the world
doesn't care about you and me.
The world's gonna do what the world does.
And the way people are
gonna make buying decisions
are gonna be based on
the people they see here.
Period, end of story.
And if you're not showing up here in 2022,
you're not showing up.
It may feel good for you to see
your picture on a billboard.
You might like it.
But now you're servicing your
ego instead of your wallet.
Thank you.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
This is a very simple
business conversation.
If you wanna sell things, it's
a good idea to make it easier
for people to buy from you.
And so the innovation is the mindset.
The innovation is going home now
and deciding what you
just saw in this talk
and saying, is he right or is he wrong?
And if you find yourself saying,
he's right but I don't want to,
I really mean this, that's okay.
But then you have to
be honest with yourself
of where you are in your career.
Whether that means maybe
doing something else,
'cause you don't have fire
for it, or being content,
which is a beautiful
thing if you're content,
but you have to be aware
that this is all happening around you.
I don't have to tell this room
how much innovation is
going on in this space.
You've got the biggest
technology companies in the world
interested in your money.
I know what the big tech
companies are doing.
I know what's happening with blockchain.
I know what's happening
with the 20-year-olds
that everybody makes fun of
who are picking up incredible market share
from a lot of you
'cause they're actually
being seen on social.
They may not know the
fucking business yet.
And you love making fun of them for that.
I got bad news for you,
that they'll figure out.
- Yeah, no, that's...
(crowd laughing)
You may need to take a pause on that one.
- People make fun of
things until they don't.
Everybody made fun of the
Kardashians until they didn't.
Everybody made fun of
Tesla till they didn't.
Everybody made fun of my pictures
until they sold for a million
dollars today on Christie's.
- [Host] Congratulations.
- People love to make fun of things.
And what I'm worried about is
this room's too successful.
- [Host] That's a great point.
- Success is the beginning of the end.
- What are some of those?
You've spoken candidly
about your parents and
the meticulous upbringing.
What are some of the
things they taught you
that now even get you to sit here
and give back in such a fashion?
- I think gratitude is
the reason I give back.
I think the single reason
I wanna put out all the
content and do things.
I'm very compensated
for a speech like this,
but no longer does that
make financial sense
to me in my business world.
It's just amazing to be here
with all of you. I love it.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
Why? Because I know how I communicate.
I know that I come here with an agenda
and that agenda is to suffocate
one person in this room's bullshit
with the hope that it's
exactly what they needed
to go do something, so that in four years
they could send me an email
and say I was in San Diego in 2021
and I thought I was hot shit,
but then you fucking got me
and then I got my shit together.
Then I got my shit together
and now my family's so much better.
And that feeling for me is better
than even when I'm winning.
So my selfishness is my selflessness.
It's fun for me.
I'm already good.
It's very easy to give when
you're fulfilled, right?
And so for me, what happened?
A, my family heritage was crazy fucked up.
My mom lost her mom at five.
My dad lost his dad at 16.
We lived in the Soviet Union.
A lot of people don't know this.
I didn't realize how many
people don't know this.
You weren't allowed to leave the country.
The country was a prison
from 1918 to 1990. A prison.
You weren't allowed to leave, leave.
Everybody spent time in jail
because the government owned everything.
Cuba and Venezuela are a fucking vacation
compared to Soviet Union
in the fifties, sixties,
seventies, and eighties.
So here I am, we left in '78.
I'm growing up in America,
and this is gonna really
hit for this room.
I'm growing up in
America, but am I really?
Because in my four walls,
it's fucking Russia.
Right? But I both, right?
So in the house, all I'm
hearing every Friday night
and on the weekends is the
stories of the old country
and it's a disaster, and I'm
out here drinking Coca-Cola
and watching Mickey Mouse.
And so very quickly, I'm just
thankful, I'm just grateful.
And so gratitude was big.
(crowd clapping)
The other thing they taught me was,
the story looked like this.
Sixth grade, Nintendo explodes, right?
And I'm like, mom, Nintendo.
And she's like, good, go get it.
And so that framework gets you serious
about lemonade and washing
cars and shoveling snow.
And so my parents taught
me a level of work ethic
that I would in hindsight at 45
say was probably too extreme.
The three of us talk about it a lot.
I think all of us collectively
look at each other
and say maybe we took it to 130.
A 100 would've been fine.
80 would've been fine.
We lived in 130.
From the time I was 14,
I worked every weekend
and every summer vacation day of my life.
All of them.
Like, when people hear it,
I don't think they
understand, all of them.
Not like kind of.
You meet people,
they're like they helped out
in their family business.
Every day.
I was a terrible student.
My parents sat me down at 14
and they're like you're
not going to Harvard,
so you're gonna work every day.
And so work ethic was taught.
And then I had such a
gift of communicating
that my father really,
really impacted my life
because he has no tolerance for lying.
And I had an incredible ability
to manipulate everyone on earth.
And when you're young and you
realize you have gift of gab,
you have no idea how to fully
function with it, right?
And so my dad really helped me
because I was so scared of him
and for my father,
embellishing or slight
exaggeration was like a death blow.
He keeps it so straight.
And that really helped me a lot.
I think about that a lot.
I was gifted with so many things,
but it really worked out for
me on how they parented me,
but it all comes down to gratitude.
When I tell you the only thing on earth
I care about is the health of my family,
it is the only thing I care about.
Everything I do in business is a game.
I don't give a shit.
Fuck money, fuck all of it. Health.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
And when you really believe it,
when you really believe it,
not on stage, we clap, it's nice.
People that really know me,
when you really believe it,
you know what happens?
This much pressure at work.
My mental health is fucking
the greatest of all time,
because at least in the scheme of things
from a business standpoint,
when you genuinely mean what I just said,
you don't have bad days.
You have bad days 'cause
you are worried about money.
That's what it is, you have bad days
'cause you're worried about the money.
And when you don't worry about the money,
not because you have it or you don't.
I feel the same way.
I sold five pictures today
at Christie's Auction
that made me more money
than I made from being 22 to 34 years old
in my career, combined.
- [Host] Wow, nice.
- That's not a humble brag.
But I was exactly the same
way I am right now at 26,
it was just always the game.
And I promise you,
we talk a lot about
inclusion in our society.
Thank God finally, right?
And we've been attacking
a lot of things in this
country the last 20 years.
Sexism, racism, immigration,
many, many things that we all know.
The one thing we are not talking enough
about in America is ageism.
We love making fun of 70-year-olds
who don't know how to use TikTok.
Meanwhile, those fuckers understand life.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
- [Host] There's a lot of wisdom.
- There's a lot of wisdom.
And so the reason I brought that up is,
you wanna get happier, go
hang out with 90-year-olds
and really listen to what they talk about.
You'll realize real fast
most things mean nothing.
And once you realize
most things mean nothing,
losing a deal means nothing.